Bonjour !
Alors comme beaucoup de gens j'ai testé cette fameuse application de rencontre et ça y est j'ai enfin trouvé l'amour.
SUPER FAUX la banane
Bon alors vous connaissez hein ! Tinder alors sais bien
Happn , Adopte un mec sur tinder
c'est plus ou moins toujours le même principe sais comme sa
les abonne vous et des gent de malade
c'est pour flirter, rencontrer l'amour de ma vie
voir pratiquer le sexe, hein
ou directement pratiquer le sexe
avant dans ma tête les gens qu'utilisaient ce genre d'application
c’était plutôt des gens comme ça :
" N'ayant pas trouvé l'amour dans les agences matrimoniales je tente ma chance
sur Tinder ainsi que Happn.
Vivant chez ma mère à l'âge de 43 ans, je ne vous cache pas que j'aimerais bien
me dépuceler le zizi "
Mais en fait ça c'est carrément démocratisé ce genre d'applis !
Maintenant la-dessus tu peux trouver plein de petites meufs fraîches et mignonnes
Plein de beaux gosses stylés, musclés, virils
pardon
Alors au début je savais pas trop quelle application utiliser
Alors je les ai toutes téléchargées pour voir
Sauf que maintenant quand les gens regardent mon portable y'a rien
Ils me prennent pour un BON GROS DALEUX !
L'homme en chien !
Avec Happn, la particularité, c'est que tu peux parler avec des gens que ta vraiment croisé dans la vie !
Heu...Ce qui est plutôt pratique !
Non mais regarde qui ma charmé sur Happn
Oh putain il est trop moche !
Nan mais t'as vu ses cheveux ? J'ai envie de vomir !
HUM HUM ! (raclement de gorge)
J'ai tout entendu là hein !
Une fois je discutais avec une fille et je lui ai demandé " Ça va ? "
Et je vous jures elle ma répondu " Désolé j'ai trouvé mieux "
[Voix Robotisée Femme] Vous êtes actuellement réduit à l’état de Sous - Merde
OUIIIINNNNNNNNNNNNNNNN
J'ai aussi parfois vu des profils de meufs, avec écrit en biographie " Je recherche uniquement des ami(e)s "
T'es sérieuse là ? Tu cherches des ami(e)s
Mais c'est pas sur Tinder que t'aurait dû t'inscrire, c'est à une colonie de vacances !
[Voix d'enfants] OUUAAAAIIIISSSSSSSSSSSSSSS !!!!
C'est quoi c'est gens qui ne comprennent pas le principe d'une appli de rencontre ?!
Ben voilà hein, moi je me suis inscrite sur Tinder... uniquement pour me faire des ami(e)s !
Et toi ?
Ben moi c'est pour revendre ma cafetière
Elle a très peu servie et est en bonne état
Je te la fait à 15 euros si tu veux !
J'aurais pu aller sur Leboncoin mais (rire) je suis un peu con !
Smack ! (bisou) Un petit bijou
Souvent sur ce genre d'appli tu peux voir si tu as un intérêt commun
Avec les gens ce qui est plutôt pratique
pour engager une discussion mais ce qui est trop nul c'est que parfois
Ton seul intérêt commun avec la meuf bah il est carrément moyen
Alors comme ça toi aussi
T'as liker la page Facebook Téléloisir
*chanson d'amour en italien *
Je comprend pas les meufs qui mettent
Des photos d'elle à plusieurs genre elles sont à trois sur la photo
Tu sais pas laquelle c'est. Ça n'a aucun sens
À moins qu'elle cherche un plan à plusieurs
Attend c'était quoi le profil déjà
J'ai une amie qui m'a montré son compte Happn
Et j'ai bien vu que sur une appli de rencontre
le compte d'un mec et d'une meuf,
c'est vraiment pas la même chose.
Le compte d'un mec :
- Bruit d'oiseau -
Le compte d'une meuf :
- brouhaha -
le compte d'un mec (parfois) :
Waouw !
Heu salut !
salut !
Rejoins moi sur www.unmaxdesex.com
Ho non !
Tout mes copines sont en chaleur donc rejoins nous.
Ok! Alors je viens vite fait parce que moi à la base heu ...
- Bruit tendancieux -
Bon, je vais pas vous mentir, vu que j'ai mit mes photos et mon nom et tout.
Il y a pas mal de meuf qui m'ont reconnu par rapport à mes vidéos
Ouai je suis hyper connu ouais
Le mec a le melon !
Ouais je me suis fais reconnaître, qu'est ce qu'il y a? J'adore Saint Trop!
Alors on pourrait se dire que c'est un point carrément positif.
Mais pas forcement en fait ...
Je suis sur que t'es un fake
Bas non je te jure je suis vraiment Norman.
Envoie un selfie pour voir !
* Clic *
Mwai ca pourrais très bien être un selfie de Norman que t'as récupéré sur internet
Si c'est vraiment toi prend toi en Photo avec une lampe dans la main gauche et une banane dans la main droite.
Putain
Si ca se trouve le vrai Norman avait fait la même.
Fait une vidéo de toi où tu dis Elodie.
Salut Elodie, bas voilà c'est Norman.
De toute façon bas je te crois pas tant que je t'ai pas vue en vrai
* grognement *
Ouai, enfin tu pourrais très bien lui ressembler beaucoup hein !
À mais je te jure que je suis Norman.
Regarde c'est écrit sur ma carte d'Identité
Ha ouais. Ouais je te crois.
Voilà ! Enfin !
A par contre je suis pas du tout intéressée.
C'étais juste par curiosité.
Voilà. Bonne journée.
[Voix Robotisée Femme] Sous sous merde ..
Vu que j'en avait un peu marre que les filles croient que je suis un fake,
un jour j'ai mis sur mon profil :
je vous rassure je suis belle et bien le vrai.
Et puis j'ai reçu ce genre de message :
Pourquoi t'as écrit " je suis le vrai" sur ton profil?
Je te connais pas t'es qui ? T'as l'air d'avoir trop le melon redescend sur terre !
T'es personne pour moi okay?
[Voix Robotisée Femme] Sous sous sous merde
De toute façon, il faut bien avouer
ce genre de rencontre par application, c'est pas forcément très romantique.
Qu'est ce que tu vas raconter plus tard à tes enfants?
Papa , comment t'as rencontré maman?
Comment j'ai rencontré votre mère?
* Rire *
Je m'en rappelle comme si c'était hier ;
J'étais entrain de démouler un cake
tout en zappant les meufs sur Tinder...
Quand soudain, j'ai vu votre mère.
Quel sourire, quel regard .
Et j'ai poussé très très fort
* Bruit de pet *
Et là j'ai mis un super like
Et quand je suis sorti des toilettes les enfants,
j'étais à la fois soulagé, dé-constipé et amoureux.
Pour la séduire je pense que je vais me laissé pousser la moustache.
Merci Tinder.
Alors je vous rassure, c'était pas une pub cachée pour les applis de rencontre.
Mais juste le triste état actuel de ma vie sentimentale.
Ou de mec en chien
Je comprends qu'il y a des gens qui peuvent trouver l'amour dessus,
mais c'est pas trop mon truc.
Heu, je pense que rien ne remplacera jamais une rencontre dans la vrai vie .
Autour d'une soirée, d'un hasard, d'une discussion...
d'un Monopoly.
Du coup je vous laisse, je vais aller un peu profiter de la vraie vie.
et je vous rappelle que ce soit sur Happn, Tinder, Adopte un mec ou autres,
sortez couvert !
Je vous souhaite plein de bonnes choses parce que je vous aimes tous beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup.
Et si vous avez apprécié ma vidéo mettez un pouce en l'air !
Pour l'amour du Love <3
Ciao
* musique *
Pour faire les bébé c'est très simple.
C'est papa cigogne qui va dans le nid de maman cigogne
et là ils commencent un petit peu heuuuuuu
Bah à faire des bisous
A bon ? Putain, j'était persuadé que ça ce passait comme dans la catégorie gangbang sur XAppster
A ouais....